yep we are the exact two people you
would expect to be reacting to this
right now bearded men bearded men in
their
late 20s slash early 30s
we are the target market we're gonna
watch today from the greg and cat that's
greg sulkin's channel wizards of waverly
place reunion with david henry and
jennifer stone
i actually reconnected with uh david
henry just recently over the phone he's
got a lot of exciting
things coming up i've hung out with
jennifer stone before spot doesn't
remember me but i think greg sulcum
would remember me
too handsome of a devil oh yeah and you
shouldn't hand it over your name
he should be stopped he should be put
down he's she's he's way too handsome
it's too much so are you david if
anyone's likely to actually come across
this it's david
probably cause i'm gonna send it to him
send it to greg and then he can see hey
maybe david should come on sometime
that would be cool that would know
everything is gonna be
a breeze anywho and we'll justify the
means
let's check this out
well you know everything is going to be
a dream
hi guys welcome back to the channel this
week we have some
incredibly special people here on my
left is jennifer stone who you guys may
know as
harper from wizards away blue place and
on our far right we have mr david henry
who played
justin russo from mrs wakeley place
going down memory lane was so fun the
first time that we wanted to sort of do
it again none of them have aged
trivia make sure if you want to reboot
to like comment and let us know let's
get that reboot going
yeah there you go don't forget comment
below like below
i'm going to get out of here
disappearance go clear it
well that was easy opinion is what you
think of things
like my opinion of that dress hopper
is that it's beautiful oh thank you her
character was the best because you
did some crazy things you were a great
sport about it and you made it better
you know like
you put smiles on people's faces by
doing all sorts of things i get comments
to this day people are like do the crazy
funky junky hat we should totally do
that
hold on wait a minute what what's that
a hat a crazy
junkie this is david's tick-tock
you were saying the winner of this
competition will choose the theme of the
next
wizards of waverly place video that
hopefully we all do together jennifer
and david below
is a pen and some paper comment below
your score see if you know the show
better than australia i hope not i
really hope not yeah
i'm so ready yes how many siblings were
in the russo family a
two e three c four three five b
three three b three
it was a b c or d after a good start
here how many seasons of the show were
there
a three b four c
[Music]
i was on set once a week for the first
season always
oh david had like an entourage man
we all brought guests
so we i would just he he would roll with
like 15 people man it was lit before lit
was a thing
i have never heard you sound like a dad
until now well nobody tried to explain
drip to me and i
still don't understand i don't even know
what drip is drip coffee
no no not exactly i was like broken
what's happening
david's a dad now yeah i heard drip and
i was like absolutely
are you guys ready yes so drink ready
what disney channel show took over the
wizards of waverly place set
after you guys round oh wow i have no
idea
hannah montana c sunny with a chance or
d jesse
sweet life on correct oh damn
i was going to say swap never even heard
which disney channel star sang amongst a
live audience during a live take
a miley cyrus b demi lovato c ravens
demi lovato
hillary
there was a break between shooting and
out of nowhere just this voice from
heaven just belted out in the audience
on the microphone
insanely gorgeous voice singing i think
christina aguilera better than christina
all the network executives at disney
world
which person did not guest star on the
show jessica alba b dwayne johnson c
shakira or d jessica wait you have to
write something right
i know okay if i'm right about one wrong
way yeah hey where was i
i wasn't there either i'm dwayne johnson
oh
you're doing johnson that's when he was
doing all those disney movies
what city does the series take place in
new york chicago be miami c
new york or d los angeles okay look at
that now we're back
what is the first word of the theme song
a u
b w wow yeah where d seems
well you know everything's gonna be a
dream okay but why would you start a
sentence with well
like you're gonna explain something well
what was greg's least favorite mason
greyback outfit a
a multi-colored jumper b a red v-neck
sweater over a blue t-shirt
c a pink colored shirt with a green
t-shirt with alex's face on it
but looking back on it they were like
very tight your pants are aggressive
they're some very tight pants so at what
point did you get out of the title
yeah that's a great question i mean let
me think about it that's the next one
that the end no doubt will be what it
seems d that the end no doubt will make
you
seen see at the end no doubt will
justify the means or
d that the end no doubt will justify our
scream
[Music]
i'm not not too good i i i'm still right
we show first and then he looks at ours
yeah what did the spell proton neutron
back to one do
a turned alex into a mac genius he
turned harper into a fashion icon c
removed mason's werewolf hair or d
turned justin back into normal size
turn justin back yeah all right you know
the answer d
just made that makes sense for those
science remedies
that's correct again alex russo takes
all the points
where did alex meet mason hey a
restaurant be a basketball game c
in art class or d a family dinner you
missed this one i swear i don't know
i'm sorry he's going to go up ah crap
i've gotten two wrongs who is harper's
biggest crush
justin
where was the russo family layer located
a through the back of the freezer and
the sub shop b
in the attic of their part the back of
the freezer in the sub shop
we have no idea they just got that
sometimes it wasn't
okay correct i'm so happy that i got it
right
how many love interests did justin have
over the course of this series oh jesus
there's more blue where
[Music]
why did mason and alex break up for the
first time a he was moving away with his
family b
he got turned into a werewolf forever
see he wanted b juliette d
justin just didn't like him greg got it
b how does that know your she's a wizard
a she uses magic to teleport them to the
beach
she gives her a cupcake in space see she
uses magic to bring a mannequin to life
or d
she uses magic to make her a sewing seat
any clue over there
c sounds like a hygiene i didn't have
any clue but i was just watching your
shape of your pen
so i know it's i know it's that i
remember
damn three wrong chair and then just
constantly being like in spite
david david looks upset
with a wizard my best friend's a wizard
what was justin allergic to oof i
had no idea a cinnamon b flower c
sadness or d all of the about all of the
above really
this is a really good question blue on
me i didn't even touch you
i'm not super confident about my answer
right now let me go with the same answer
just in case
then i've already written down our
answers we're just waiting right can you
just flip
i'm gonna change it so that wait i
literally here's my thing i'm gonna
change it because i've seen
gems if i do something different then
we've got a shot how many has greg scene
i feel
duke no it's happening it's an asc in a
d no it's actually a name you guys are
all wrong what was it what was it it
says you're allergic to everything
if you get it wrong you lose two points
if you get it right you get two points
after the last day of filming what
happened hey
cass went on a vacation to go b the cast
cry together
c the cast kissed each other d the cast
drain together the cat's crazy
drink together what happened is the show
ended and all of us cried and then they
actually
rolled a whole table of shots that's her
alcohol
in front of everyone the people who were
of age drink no one else
for the rest of us and everyone else i
don't know if his shots are champagne i
can't remember and everyone had everyone
had a drink that's why you remember this
one
i know i totally i think it was tequila
it was cause i remember
like being like super bummed that i had
apple juice
[Laughter]
so what did he get he told me it was
crying david's right so so then
i won't tell you why
[Laughter]
i guessed like at least 40
[Music]
if you have any suggestions please
comment below david will be looking at
them and hopefully we'll see you guys
there
and let us know if you beat us so with
the bonus round in the end i had
16 points greg had 14 jen had 14 let us
know if you did better than us
oh i'm gonna calculate in between the
cuts you're putting
guys thank you so much for watching if
you guys want to see more wizards of
waverly place videos please like comment
and subscribe in the meantime have an
amazing week and we will see you next
saturday
bye guys bye bye greg time to calculate
the points
all right playing it back i got 17
because of that bonus round fact checked
david henry
you're still way more successful than
both john and i combined
that's right why don't you come on and
share some behind-the-scenes stories we
can take a quiz right here
it's funny man i owe so much to david
and the henry's
the whole family i mean i've never met
his wife but jim linda
yeah lorenzo james family the
surrounding
fan because in eighth grade is when
david went to school with us
and then you were really close to them
then i and then you you set
you out get out of here john yeah i want
to be friends with the kid who we
thought was max keeble
that's right yeah that was the first
question everybody asked
i i love the hell out of the henry
family i still they're a big part of my
formative years as a teenager for sure
it's funny of watching this back because
uh i guess most of these
the other part is i was actually with
david when he
shot man it'd be great to bring him on
here and like talk about it sometimes
he auditioned for it i don't know if he
even remembers this he auditioned for it
was fred savage who was in the
who's the director i think of the pilot
remember he walked out of the audition
he's like i blew it i totally blew it
and then as we were leaving
director producer told him to come back
in he eventually got the part
and the pilot was very different i don't
know if i'm allowed to reveal what
details
there were that were different not
gritty yeah it was really dark and heavy
finally yeah it was like only
yeah he did bring like 20 people today
i would come by for the taping like for
the first season every friday i think is
when they would film didn't really come
by after that david always had like a
gazillion people there we
met greg sulkin um at brandon melgar's
restaurant spies
very charming individual that was right
before he got runaways right he was
meeting
he was talking about how he just got a
marvel show yeah
we were sitting there wishing we could
talk about it to the world
and i hung out with jennifer one day
with
a random eighth grade reunion that john
did not come to and brandon brought her
by
uh she was great but i highly doubt she
remembers that i just wanted to make
this wizards video about my experience
my limited experiences
[Music]
in here to tell about if they remember
meeting you yeah
this is such a hyped up demanded reunion
that they want and what's funny is i
feel like greg sulkin is taking care of
it all in his home
i know we keep going we want a reunion
we want to reboot we're
reading i'm like dude you're doing it
already for you already got david here
now you got jennifer
you just gotta get selena and jt austin
and
um and you know dumb dumb dad
i'm sure that they're down hey i mean if
we want to reboot the show this is
probably a decent strategy for doing so
because think of half the things that
get picked up out of youtube anyway and
if you get enough views you should show
that the kids
out there both who were watching before
and who could discover it now
are interested but this show still gets
a lot of viewers and the fan base is
still pretty intense
i think it was the first disney channel
original show
to get uh like to win an actual emmy for
like
i forget what it was for for great david
best
show ever david henry magnum opus award
man yeah they have an age at all no it's
it's it's
kooky even with david feeling like a dad
now and i think he has another kid on
the way i track david's age by his
haircuts
yeah i feel like his hair gets more
mature
he used to be like cool spiky hair back
then
as he gets older it turns more into his
dad yeah just a more
cropped more economical more sharp and
that's how we can
track david lee but if they did a reboot
like an actual reboot it could work
because
they look the same listening to the fact
about the last one and everybody having
like a drink at the end of the show i
was like wait a minute there must have
been enough people
on that cast who are like of age yeah so
yeah
everyone's a little older than they
seemed already so that probably works in
a reunion's favor be great try to get
david to come on here sometime
i think it's impossible and it will
never happen yeah
you heard it here the guy's got some
very exciting things coming up
like something pretty pretty exciting
that maybe
in this month keep a lookout follow him
on social media because
he's got very something very exciting to
premiere that i think you guys would
really like what is a waverly place do
you want a reunion
let us know do you want me to try to get
david to come on this channel what about
selena gomez because i know i definitely
can't do that what about
jt austin he's buff now is he oh my god
i i saw a photo like a week ago i really
want you to come
that wasn't a joke i want i want it
don't don't hurt
don't beat me up john could give two
shits about everyone else
just jtos jake t austin man as long as
he doesn't kick the crap out of me
rest the cast whatever all right guys
well you can subscribe
to the real rejects click that
notification bell to get notified
whenever we got another video up to
wherever we cover something disney
channel related
last but not least
so with regarding which patron to shout
out for this particular video i
said who is a wizard at our patreon page
john and i both agreed
it's j.n valente a man we've been
shouting out for months with every shout
out going where the hell have you been
jay
i like to give personalized shout outs
and yet i haven't heard a peep from you
in forever post a list of the shout outs
with links to everyone
shout out at our patreon page that way
they don't have to go through every
video we upload in the month and one of
the first comments that came in
was j.n a man who likes to appear and
reappear
like a wizard yay i first saw it here
and then saw it and then responded
silence icebreaker for sure thanks a
gazillion
particularly as i didn't comment on it
elsewhere is that it i mean
am i forgiven i did give you a sign of
still being alive and all that
many kudos and celluloid on you god says
i'm ancient
he did it all himself he proved himself
and the great thing is like every time
you read
a jn expression i like to think that
it's a magical incantation of its own
because you know it's always a little
bit of a
rollercoaster ride and i have to imagine
that somewhere somehow some kind of
magical thing is taking place each time
he comments and that's
why he is so tactful
j.n
[Music]
you really had a hammer at home didn't
you i mean we i thought we already did a
pretty good job on tying in this wizard
bit
and then you were not i mean let me let
go with a little next you gotta
bring every bit of a joke out of that
comedy berry all right you gotta get all
that juice